تسعدون هي من حضرت اجتماعه وزراء الخارجيه
العرب في العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس من بين
الحضور وزير الخارجيه كل من تونس والجزائر
وزير الدوله القطري فيما ارسلت بقيه الدول
ممثلين دبلوماسيين اما الجامعه العربيه
فغابت امانتها العامه مشترطه موافقه 14
دوله عربيه حتى يحضر الامن العام شرط اثار
استغراب المضيفين
استغربنا ابتداع امانه الجامعه شرطا غير
موجود في الميثاق واللوائح وغير مسبوقه
بان تؤكد ان هناك 14 دوله لابد ان تكتب
حضورها كتابيا مما وضع الكثير من الدول في
احراج الاصطفاف وبذلك تكون الجامعه قد
اقحمت نفسها في الانحياز الواضح لاحدى
الدول الاجتماعيه
وهو ما ترفضه دول عربيه تشكل في شرعيه
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه برئاسه البيبه التي
تستضيف الاجتماعات في طرابلس اليوم كانت
الرساله واضحه كان حرص الحكومه على هذه
الرساله واضحه باسرارها على عقد اجتماع
رغم ربما بعض الظروف التي لم تجعل ذلك
امرا انسيابيا لكنه حدث في نهايه الامر
وعقد الاجتماع وحضر عدد من الوفود العربيه
يوضح انقسام الدول العربيه حول حضور
الاجتماعي من عدمه موقفها السياسيه من
النزاع على السلطه في طرابلس فالرئيس
الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان فتحي اعرب عن
شكره للدول العربيه التي غابت عن الاجتماع
واعتبر غيابها رساله واضحه في رفض شرعيه
استمرار حكومه
الدول العربيه وبعض الدول عن هذا الاجتماع
كان له الاثر السلبي ولكن اقامته مثل هذه
الاجتماعات في طرابلس يعد نجاح امنيا
للحكومه هنا حسب وجهه نظر
البعضرابلس العربيه